le solite storie senza nell'italia dei
palazzi nuova challenge tre colori di
pennarelli gialle tutte le simpatiche
noi avremo una serie di disegni qua che
dobbiamo colorare e possiamo colorarli
solamente con 3 colori di pennarelli che
andremo a pescare poi uno alla volta
quindi potrebbe capitarci verde e il
giallo e marrone verrone per colorare
pixma del tempo dei lunghi che hanno già
un colore prestabilito pure in base ai
pennarelli negi capitano avranno un
colore completamente diverso e voi nei
commenti potrete votare ogni turno chi
vince se vinco io o se vince milano
se volete vedere altre challenge del
genere o se volete una seconda parte di
questa challenge per l'occasione abbiamo
comprato dei pennarelli particolari
allora in realtà non ho pennarelli a
dover abbandonare perché in genere lu
colori o abbiamo questa tesi prender i
classici pennarelli si curavano da tiger
network perché proviamo a prendere
questi che sarebbero dei pennarelli un
po particolari abbiamo questi
praticamente tutti è l se li abbiamo
visti dal video di frog che appunto dice
che sono i copy krausz il prof
andate a vedere sul canale bravissima
attrice illustratrice bravissima oltre
che su questi in partica lavoro quindi
andate a vederla poi comunque può vedere
appunto roba pozzi pennarelli quadri non
siamo per niente
niente registratori vediamo se volete
vedere i video vecchi abbiamo fatto del
santos e disegni che sono molto degli
attenti troppo divertenti
quindi non so se riusciremo usarli che
ho preso vari colori e tutto abbiamo
speso tipo 15 esperti pennarelli un po
questo settore abbiamo mai messo presto
oggetto di marrone quindi e abbiamo il
marrone scuro marrone chiaro e arancione
giallo è giallo scuro viola scuro lilla
è rosa poi abbiamo un blu scuro celeste
e azzurro e per ferire abbiamo i colori
preferiti
non solo la verde scuro verde pisello è
verde chiaro allora andiamo mischiarli
ora della scatola perché dovremmo
pescarli senza guardare meglio allora
iniziamo il primo disegno basse giriamo
il foglio tutti allora il trentino
dovremmo colorare il logo della apple la
mela morsicata
allora tappa di gli occhi troppo di gli
occhi negli occhi tappati
primo valore di vitale è un lilla boom
della puglia sorella gambe guarda giallo
giallo chiaro pero sta meglio chi
chiuderà poi trovata dai hai deciso di
andare con i toni del viola via curio
realtà sei fortunato che queste tonalità
blu scuro che volgiamo diversa parole
verde scuro con i due viola però nella
mela bocca mi domenico marrone
quindi dobbiamo prender collega giallo
blu e marrone ma che cola i grossi
vecchio viola vino la rosa ok siamo
pronti
1 stimati sono un po freddo io chiamo
dobbiamo guardare
nell'altro già mi piace mi piace un
sacco o che ho fatto
[Musica]
ok abbiamo fatto la nostra prima
generazione t3 2 1 carina io riesco a
rovinare i disegni anche se sono impuri
palla piazzata la mia ho cercato di fare
una sorta di colore pica sul tipo con il
marrone però il gruppo e non c'entrano
molto quindi l'ho messo solo un po qua
quindi votate chi vince per questo primo
round ajo ciao vitale la tua visione
molto però la mia originale abbiamo il
nostro prossimo disegno 12 cacchetta
italia credo che questa sia un gelato di
vedere che colori capitare
[Musica]
cos'è giallo anche tu vai mio colore
preferito
ma che bello ma che vai vai 21 come
formula tutti i pennarelli colorano
benissimo noi non è che siamo esperti
però con un bene a che punto sei ci sono
quasi poi finito già pronti alla
regolazione
e la sua scrivere e machetto quindi lato
è molto accesa come colore sembra fatta
appunto tutta con evidenziatori mai
usato sono più colore o usato anche il
giallo sul bordo per home l'ha coperto
il verde c'è pure una linguetta si veda
la lingua originale duetto gialla darli
meglio che ti tricolore mi avete che gli
usati tutti eppure alternati allora chi
votate per il secondo turno amica o
vitale quale vi piace di più questo
oppure siamo noi bravi a colorare con
trasmessa dallo stato per tutto il
contorno degli occhi rosa quindi sembra
una cacchetta spiritati ho fatto solo il
contorno celeste allora il terzo round
per l'ultimo turno andiamo a svelare
cosa dobbiamo colorare il resto è un
ricordo
questo è più complicato perchè a
distanza con di lima da amare vado io
credo di vedere come si l'acqua
raccontiamo esca re kiro micciani
iniziato questa volta volo vai di colore
verde
perseguitato va perseguita devo sempre
dire il colore ad alta voce così non
vado mai nome del giallo ma ti piace
proprio valore arancione
bye bye cene
roma 15 set i miei tre colori invernali
si sono visti a questo ritorno ma non
pensarci devo portarci tocca a me dai
formalismi
vediamo un po
sancito dai contorni aiuto di più brava
colorare abbiamo cambiato punta dal
pennarello si è preso un altro punto
adesso non sono più pura di come farlo
tu sei sicuro chiaro io sono sicurissimo
quindi stai già bene come fare tutto ciò
[Musica]
e la rivelazione del segreto e 12
bellissimo ma teniamo
[Musica]
sarà perché gli ho messo il mascara che
ho fatto procediamo anche perché hai
avuto una bella idea di fare le strisce
qua nella coda le strisce colorate
farmaci si siano più colori molto bello
è che sembra non lo so sembra un
unicorno punk tipo no l'unicorno ribelle
vestito di verde truccato invece un po
più classico rosa è stato carino anche
tu ti alleni già si stacco il tuo bravo
se è stato proprio bravo come combinato
ai colori anche il tuo piace molto ma
non ho capito però perché gli hai fatto
le macchie sulla sono dei cuoricini del
vecchio da mucca pizzini allora votate
per il terzo round sevizia vita ho vinto
e vitale quale unicorno vi piace di più
questo o questo primo round martora pro
tibet è una
troverete di vedere come applicazione
con colori diversi comuni shiny messo
tutta me stessa cosa ma che ne verrà
fuori un po cominciare nei commenti di
colore figurati che una volta che ho
notato però guardate un po voi cosa vi
ricordate che ha nella coda pikachu
perché io mi ricordo che ho del marrone
alla base oppure una parte nera qua
anch'io mi ricordo una parte n'erano
forse ma prona
però sicuramente gli manca scrivete nei
commenti statali manca era mediatico non
riuscira a molti piace ma riesce anche
di un altro tipo di possessi tutto verde
un picasso d'erba stessi tutto rosso
lupi caccia di fuoco e senso tutto
d'acqua ecco ok basta sia un pikachu
d'acqua per chimica qualche tonalità del
verde niente vai lì la image il giorno è
lì la sofferenza si sia un po più con
l'ubicazione verde alla malizia del
verdi tia battuta chiama prodotta
vai di una pubblica certo siamo pratici
[Musica]
che stai già come farlo io assolutamente
no non mi ricordo neanche quali sono
tutti i colori e lo vediamo ma sto
pensando
[Musica]
allora come sta andando benissimo
sei contento volto quindi di che tipo lo
farai tu [ __ ] sul mio tipo desta
sicuramente il mio tipo etico electro
con di euro
ah sì elettro erba o e ho vinto abbiamo
frontiera rimasti a lettere di una talea
allora può stranissimo federer picas
inverni innanzitutto il mio pikachu di
tipo erba e acqua
infatti la maggior parte avverte con
delle tonalità verde ti ho aggiunto tipo
le zampine di sopra tipo i guanti
celesti è che le barzellette e un po di
sé lesse qua nella cosa anch'io che mi
hanno fatto la stessa cosa per le
continue ho messo anche lo smalto che
tipo è
è lo stesso tipo elettro e tu piccazzo
dinamica c'è un pic ha certificato nel
senso che non è solo elettrico ma è
anche confuso ecco perché e quindi anche
tipo di tipo spettro di tipo spettro si
è quindi votate quale vi piace di più il
pikachu verde o picasso tipo spettro
elettro allora ecco il riepilogo degli
altri disegni consistono i miei e questi
quelli di vitale scrivete nei commenti
quale vi è piaciuto di più allora vi
dico quale è piaciuto di più a me dei
miei
a me è piaciuto di più la cacchetta non
so perché mi piace tanto questo mix di
colore invece dei tour mi piace un sacco
unimondo ea me dei miei dei miei piace
tanto di cacio e di lei tuoi in questo e
l'unicorno scrivete come invece quale vi
piace di più
quattro disegni colorati tra i gay e
quelli di vitale del genere
lasciate un bel rai che ora vi lasciamo
a quattro cartellini e su cui cliccare
per vedere le nostre altre challenge
insieme le chance di disegno super
divertenti cliccate su quella che
preferite